bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 21
décembre voici les titres de ce journal
en cette période de crise sanitaire les
restaurateurs et traiteurs du
sud-yvelines s'unissent l'opération
cuisines en fête ressent sur une carte
interactive les professionnels qui ont
développé la vente à emporter c'est
soutenu par la députée aurore bergé à
l'initiative de laurent trochain le chef
étoilé du numéro 3 est notre invité la
venue de marc guillaume attrape le
préfet de la région ile de france a
effectué ce déplacement en fin de
semaine dernière sur le thème de la
culture
au programme visite d'une librairie du
cinéma ou encore du conservatoire de
musique
la municipalité lui a également présenté
ses projets culturels
et puis la ville de trappes célébrer la
fin d'année pendant trois jours avec
tous aux fenêtres certaines communes
yvelinois se sont en effet adapté au
contexte épidémique pour organiser tout
de même leur événement à coignières un
marché de noël était proposé mais avant
de développer ses titres les derniers
chiffres du coït 19 dans les yvelines
sur une semaine certains indicateurs
remontent vous le voyez hein c'est le
cas du nombre de personnes contaminées
pour cent mille habitants
ce qu'on appelle le taux d'incidence est
en hausse il s'établissait hier à 113
augmentation assez forte également vous
ne le voyez pas sur ce tableau du taux
de reproduction du virus depuis quelques
semaines le taux d'occupation des lits
de réanimation en ile-de-france
réaugmente également légèrement +0 3%
en ce qui concerne les autres
indicateurs hospitaliers les données
sont en revanche à la baisse les
yvelines compte moins de patients
hospitalisés et moins de patients en
réanimation sur une semaine et depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire 1014
personnes sont mortes du coronavirus
dans les hôpitaux du département parmi
les victimes nous l'avons appris ce
matin un pompiers des yvelines
andré locher médecin-colonel sapeurs
pompiers volontaires dans le département
est décédé des suites du coc vie de 19
sur son compte twitter le service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
du 78 fait part de sa douleur et
présente ses condoléances et soutien à
ses proches andré locher était marié et
père de trois enfants
la crise sanitaire qui vous le savez
contraint les restaurants notamment à
rester fermés mais certains s'organisent
et s'adapte à quelques jours des fêtes
de fin d'année si vous n'avez toujours
pas d'idées pour votre repas les
restaurateurs du sud yvelines ont la
solution pour en parler laurent trochain
est avec moi par vision conférence vous
êtes le chef étoilé du numéro 300
restants qui est situé au tremblay sur
mauldre bonsoir bonsoir et vous êtes à
l'initiative d'une opération qui
s'appelle cuisine en fait on en parle
juste après ce reportage d'eléonore
sinoquet de justin braz et cela fait une
semaine que l'opération cuisines en fête
est lancé al'approche de noël et du
nouvel an le chef étoilé laurent
trochain avec l'aide de la députée
aurore bergé à créer une cartographie du
territoire sud yvelines qui recense les
restaurateurs et traiteurs
objectif jouer collectif pour se faire
connaître dans cette période de crise
sanitaire
c'est de donner un miroir et de nous
faire connaître dans notre activité de
traiteur qui est nouvelle et qui n'est
pas notre activité d'ailleurs mais on
s'en sort on s'en sort plutôt très bien
parce que on a une clientèle qui qui
magnifique et est reconnaissante et qui
nous soutient depuis nos débuts des deux
premiers confirmant donc les initiatives
et ben depuis mars dernier beaucoup de
professionnels ont développé la vente à
emporter et la livraison avec cette
cartographie réalisée gracieusement par
l'association la fabrique de rambouillet
les restaurants peuvent donc développer
leurs réseaux de communication les gens
vont dessus et après ils peuvent choisir
par rapport à une carte google maps le
restaurant qui juge qu'ils veulent ils
cliquent dessus et après ça on voit tous
les liens de chaque restaurant dessus on
ce regroupement fait que ça ça redonne
le moral on se sent pas tout seul on se
sent tous s'entraider et ça ça ça fait
beaucoup
ça nous donne du peps pour repartir à
essayer de retrouver des solutions s'il
y en a le site cuisines en fête regroupe
donc 21 restaurants ainsi que trois
traiteurs et deux autres professionnels
de la restauration de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
un moyen de continuer à travailler en
cette période compliquée et je rappelle
que laurent trochain est avec nous par
visioconférence chef étoilé du
restaurant numéro 3 c'est au tremblay
sur mauldre et vous êtes l'initiateur de
cette opération on entendait dans ce
sujet laurent trochain restaurateurs
dire on s'entraide ça permet de
s'entraider cette opération ne donne pas
se sentir seul il est primordial de
faire front commun dans cette situation
il a fait et c'est important c'est
essentiel et c'est important
on est dans une phase difficile pour
notre profession la restauration depuis
le 14 mars et vous pouvez pas louper les
fêtes et on ne pouvait pas passer à côté
une eau fait donc l'union fait la force
et c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est ce qu'ont
réussi à faire et vous n'en êtes pas
votre coup d'essai puisque vous êtes
également à l'origine des restos
ensemble qui fédère cinq cents adhérents
pour échanger s'entraider justement des
adhérents du monde de la restauration
pourquoi cette envie pour vous de jouer
collectif finalement de ne pas rester
dans votre coin parce que comme je dis
toujours on est connu dans mon village
on est connu par nos mairies on est
connu par nos clients
elle qui aime fréquenter le restaurant
mais c'est tout ça s'arrête là et on a
besoin de jouer collectif pour échanger
notre clientèle vit toujours que au bout
c'est le client qui va choisir son
restaurant suivant l'événement qui l'a
arrêté suivant comment ils envie de
quelques donc un moment donné un avis
qui va permettre un client de d'avoir un
panel de cuisine différente
est-ce qu'il ya plus important hélas la
dimension aussi qui est importante c'est
celle du sud yvelines
il ya une dimension locale c'est ce
territoire sur lequel vous vous êtes
fédérer oui tout à fait dans le sud
yvelines environ une cinquantaine de
communes et on se connaît tous dans la
restauration on se connaît tous traiteur
restaurateur bistrot de la crêperie à
l'étoilé michelin et généralement on est
dans notre coin généralement que notre
travail seul on est isolé et là c'est
important de se dire voilà on se connaît
bien on va unir nos forces pour arriver
à montrer qu'on est là à mettre la
lumière sur nos établissements via les
réseaux sociaux via de l'âme et de
médiatisation pardon et voilà montrer ce
qu'on fait en ahl savoir faire on avait
besoin de le faire savoir et de le faire
savoir
j'imagine aussi l'idée c'est de dire à
ses habitants du sud yvelines venez
soutenir vos restaurateurs locaux
oui bien sûr c'était importante et on le
ressent déjà depuis concret de la vente
à emporter que nos clients sont là pour
nous on a envie de le soutenir et et
nous ça nous tient et ça nous fait du
bien ça et et en même temps là on peut
leur montrer que nous aussi on est là
pour eux on est là quand ils passent de
bonnes fêtes
voilà c'est 6 millions signons des
restaurateurs et si lyon des
restaurateurs et leur clientèle
alors on ne parle pas de réouverture
pour les restaurants au moins pour le 20
janvier si c'était plus tard vous le
disiez il ya une adaptation il ya un
développement de la vente à emporter
pour continuer de fonctionner de
fonctionner un tant soit peu
on imagine oui la situation pour vous
aussi pour vos collègues n est pas l est
pas au mieux aujourd'hui
alors elle est pas au mieux et la vente
à emporter ne fais pas çi d'après un à
restaurants donc il faut pas oublier que
encaissa vraiment pour la pour la survie
de nos entreprises pour la survie aussi
pour maintenir nos salaires pour
maintenir l'économie locale parce qu'on
travaille aussi avec énormément de
producteurs d'artisans d'entreprises du
secteur donc de faire cette vente à
emporter de continuer à avoir notre
activité nous permet de continuer
d'entretenir ce tissu économique local
alors la carte interactive a été
réalisée gracieusement par l'association
la fabrique avec qui vous avez été mis
en relation par la députée des yvelines
aurore bergé la carte aussi ce côté
ludique interactif ça c'était une
volonté aussi pour que ce soit très
simple aussi à vous retrouver sur sur
internet oui voilà il fallait un outil
très très simples qui permettent de
visualiser très rapidement les
établissements pars pars pars villes
villages ou par catégorie bistrot
traiteur restaurant et donc appel à
peine leur berger à la compacte et donc
la fabrique et la fabrique a été très
réactif sur sur la fabrication de de cet
outil
justement hors berger qui vous a appuyé
dans ce projet avait un mot pour vous
écouter vous à leur mère c'est le
remercier de la mobilisation actuelle
permet pour l'ensemble des restaurants
et des traiteurs du territoire et puis
dire surtout à celles et ceux qui
pourraient l'écouter et le regarde et
qu'on a la chance d'avoir des gens de
talent sur le territoire et qu'il faut
juste leur faire confiance pour le
réveillerons pour la période des fêtes
et puis après on retrouvera avec plaisir
le chemin de leur table mais qu'avant
qu'on puisse le faire il faut déjà qu'on
leur permette de continuer leur activité
saas et appuis politiques laurent
trochain on ne pouvait pas faire ça
aussi c'était nécessaire pour moi
c'était nécessaire c'est à dire que on a
tous fait appel à nos mairies et moi
j'ai pour habitude des clients aux
politiques comme il est alors pour
rester ensemble
mme nationale et là c'est vrai qu'on
voit souvent hébergés dans les médias et
je me suis dit il faut qu'on fasse appel
à elle elle est là c'est une politique a
été élu sur notre circonscription mas
faisant appel à elle donc le mail a été
fait la réponse a été très rapide et le
rendez vous a été pris avec certaines
certains restaurateurs et puis ça s'est
fait en trois jours voilà donc elle a
été réactif comme on l'attendait quoi on
l'entendait dans le reportage ça
fonctionne depuis quelques jours cette
opération est ce que les sud yves binois
justement son sont au rendez vous est ce
que ça fonctionne bien pour le moment
oui on le ressent ressent alors j'ai
encore eu on est on est 27 pour le
moment parce qu'on a eu un restaurateur
qui entend parler aujourd'hui peut nous
rejoindre dès aujourd'hui c'est possible
il n'est pas trop tard et les
restaurateurs que j'ai eu pour le moment
sont contents de cette visibilité est
alors qu'on n'arrive jamais à quantifier
mais en tant qu il y a qui a un regain
d'activité voilà donc donc ça nous fait
du bien voilà ça nous fait du bien merci
laurent trochain et bravo pour cette
belle opération chef étoilé du numéro 3
le nom de cette opération
ces cuisines en fête et le numéro 3
votre restaurant est situé au tremblay
sur mauldre vous l'avez dit les
restaurateurs peuvent encore vous
rejoindre et pour consulter aussi un
cette carte rendez vous sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
d'avoir été avec nous on prend à présent
la direction du nord des yvelines avec
une autre opération ce week end et
restaurateurs du vésinet ont été invités
à s'implanter dans le marché de la ville
l objectif les mettre en valeur et au
permettre aussi de réaliser de la vente
à emporter dans ce contexte difficile le
reportage de justin brasier de mickaël
millero c'est une première dans la ville
du vésinet ce samedi 19 décembre
trois restaurants de la commune ont été
invités sur le marché cette opération
inédite a été lancée par le groupe géré
aux gestionnaires de l'espace
objectif aider les restaurateurs pendant
cette crise sanitaire
ils ont
vu réinventer un petit peu leur mode de
distribution avec de la vente à emporter
et c est
avec la deuxième vague de nouveaux ont
fait face à une situation qui pourrait
être dur donc l'idée c'est de leur
permettre de renouer le contact avec
avec leurs clients avec les commerçants
et de réenclencher une dynamique
commerciale pour eux ce jour là ces
restaurateurs proposent aux clients de
déguster et d'emporter des plats
préparés cette opération soutenue par la
mairie semble les séduire c'était une
visibilité en plus on a bien communiqué
la sur les réseaux pour dire à tout le
monde qu'on était là que que tout le
monde passe nous voir à que ça soit un
bon moment que les gens ne nous oublie
pas continuer à occuper le terrain et
que les gens n'oublient pas on ne peut
pas disparaître pendant toute la
fermeture c'est compliqué ça met en
avant les résultats qui sont en
difficulté ou non mais ça fait quand
même une certaine publicité pour eux et
je pense que ce serait une validé 2 2
ça nous aiderait je pense que ça devrait
aussi pas mal de gens l'opération
pourrait être renouvelé d'ici le 20
janvier dans la ville date
prévisionnelle de la réouverture des
restaurants si la situation sanitaire le
permet en parallèle les restaurateurs
vont continuer le click and collect dans
l'actualité politique les élections
départementales et régionales devraient
être reportés de mars à juin 2021 en
raison de la crise sanitaire
le projet de loi portant sur le report a
été entérinée ce lundi matin en conseil
des ministres une décision ont préconisé
dans un rapport de jean louis debré
l'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel est le choix devrait
s'arrêter entre les 13 et 20 juin pour
les premier et second tours ou sur les
dates du 20 et 27 juin le texte de loi
le texte de loi sera examiné en première
lecture au sénat dans la semaine du 25
janvier donner un nouvel élan à la
politique culturelle à la vie culturelle
de trappes c'est l'ambition affichée par
la ville depuis qu'elle est entrée en
fonction en mars la ville a accueilli à
cet effet elle est entrée en fonctions
pardon en juin dernier à la ville a
accueilli à cet effet le préfet de la
région ile-de-france et le directeur
régional des affaires culturelles en fin
de semaine dernière
retour sur cette visite avec ses diaga
tsongo bixente n'a rien senti steban et
patrick jacques de dixmude démocratiser
l'accès à la culture même au temps du
coc vide
un souhait pour la mairie de trappes qui
pour cela va développer plusieurs
projets comme le plan lecture pour tous
qui sera l'occasion pour nous de
développer l'activité de la librairie le
millefeuille de lui permettre de
s'épanouir au coeur des quartiers en
pied d'immeuble et de donner aux enfants
avant même le cp l'occasion de découvrir
le livre la ville de trappes a reçu pour
l'occasion le préfet de la région ile de
france après un passage à la librairie
le millefeuille les élus territoriaux se
sont rendus au cinéma le grenier à sel
puisque l'un des projets et d'associer
la programmation culturelle aux
habitants de trappes pour les jeunes
jeunes gens par exemple d'aller à
travers la france de découvrir dans les
festivals de culture quand on sera
évidemment sortie de la période de
pandémie de découvrir les différentes
diversité culturelle de notre pays et de
les importer ici à trappes
en fin de visite les élus du département
et de la région sont allés au
conservatoire de musique et de danse
en cette période où la culture est
malmené la région souhaite soutenir ce
genre de projets culturels
la variété des projets des talents vous
fait penser qu'on pourra essayer
d'accompagner la ville de trappes dans
ses différents projets avec un fil rouge
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
ses contractualiser avec elle pour
sécuriser des crédits des actions et se
projeter dans le futur
l'après midi s'est clôturé par une table
ronde avec les acteurs associatifs et
culturels
on les représentants territoriaux et l
écoute de nos projets moi ça fait trente
ans que je me bats ici est bien de voir
que là on a une écoute de l'état fort
que ça donne envie d'aller encore plus
loin de créer des nouvelles vedettes de
de faire que cette ville elle soit
regarder aussi ailleurs comme un lieu
de culture avant tout et ça c'est
déterminant autre projet le centre
technique municipal deviendra un tiers
lieu nommé la fabrique où se mêleront
artistes et artisans attrape toujours
les familles ont pu profiter de trois
jours d'animations organisées par la
ville c'était de jeudi à samedi dernier
pas de traditionnel féerie cette année
mais des déambulations avoir directement
depuis sa fenêtre est aussi un grand jeu
de piste organisé pour les enfants
justine brasier et astrid bergère pas de
féerie de trappes massique cette année
mais un autre événement l'un remplacé
tous aux fenêtres
jeudi vendredi et samedi des
déambulations eu lieu dans tous les
quartiers parade lumineuse et sonore
déambulation d'artistes camion musicale
la magie de noël était bien là en
situation critique au fender ovulation
dans les rues pour dans trappe
on déambule au temps des
des images les légendes maastricht et
son génial même le samedi après midi un
grand jeu était organisé il fallait
résoudre des énigmes en se promenant
dans la ville l'occasion de croiser au
détour d'une rue le père noël j'ai tout
tout tout aimé et moi si content qu'elle
même moment m a laissé aller avec les n
2 et j'ai vu le père noël et nous est
donnée des baux et adoré les activités
j'adore du théâtre à parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'activités les enfants ont
aussi pu observer les illuminations de
noël cette année elles ont été
entièrement installé par le service
technique municipal
une façon de faire des économies et d'en
mettre davantage dans la ville c'était
donc un cours soulagement pour les
intermittents du spectacle qui ont pu
travailler et un peu de magie pour les
enfants et des parents
dernière ligne droite avant noël
patience il ne reste maintenant plus que
trois jours à attendre
et alors que la plupart des marchés noël
a été annulé dans les yvelines crise
sanitaire oblige celui de coignières a
été certes reporté mais s'est bien tenue
hier dimanche une aubaine pour les
commerçants et pour les habitants qui
ont pu retrouver un semblant de vie
sociale sur place astrid berges heures
un marché de noël reporté mais pas
annulé pour les habitants de coignières
c'est un plaisir ce dimanche ils sont
venus nombreux pour retrouver un
semblant de vie sociale en ce moment on
peut dire qu'on a un peut briguer quand
on n'est plus tellement libre
de vie notre vie comme il faut surtout
au niveau de la convivialité la famille
et tout ça là on retrouve des liens on
retrouve des gens c'est une bouffée
d'oxygène pour tous surtout que le
sauteur soleil est au rendez vous et les
stands sont particuliers c'est pas un
marché de noël comme d'habitude déjà par
le fait du contexte actuel et chacun a
exposé dans les stands des choses
différentes qui ne se ressemblent pas
pour les exposants c'est la dernière
chance pour vendre avant noël il espère
beaucoup de ce marché et sont ravis de
retrouver les clients
ça fait du bien battre
heureuse parce qu'on était très déçu
quand tout a été annulé et puis nous
dire ben non finalement c'est décalé
dernier week end avant noël on était
super content de participer pour les
élus le marché de noël est un moment
convivial important à conserver je pense
que les gens ont besoin de se retrouver
et d'ailleurs voyez on est nombreux
aujourd'hui sur le marché donc c'est un
vrai moment de convivialité qu'on tenait
absolument avant noël à pouvoir pouvoir
faire sur coignières au total près de 30
exposants étaient présents et le plus
attendu de tous le père noël était là et
il a un message à faire passer
il faut que les enfants restent très
sages et je vous souhaite à tous un
joyeux noël
et puis à quelques jours de noël
justement le représentant des
catholiques yvelinois tire sa révérence
monseigneur eric aumônier évêque de
versailles prend sa retraite
à 74 ans l'officialisation est arrivé en
fin de semaine dernière avec vingt ans
après vingt ans passés à la tête du
diocèse il va formuler ses adieux au
travers d'un pèlerinage qui passera par
cinq villes yvelinoise rambouillet
poissy mantes la jolie sartrouville et
versailles en attendant de connaître le
nom de son successeur l'intérim sera
assuré par l'évêque auxiliaire bruno
valentin comme administrateur diocésain
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité et rendez vous dès
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]